across Europe coronavirus lockdowns have
largely emptied the streets to reduce
the chances of person-to-person
infection in Paris residents face a 150
dollar fine if caught outside without
good reason
exercise is permitted even encouraged
but new restrictions have been imposed
along the River Seine and around the
Eiffel Tower we are at the start of this
crisis as I have reminded the French
people in the beginning of this week we
put in place measures to absorb this
first wave it's a race against the virus
despite nearly two weeks in lockdown
Italy has seen the numbers dead and
infected hitting record new heights
people are only allowed out for work
medical reasons or emergencies and those
allowances are expected to be made even
tighter this weekend this is just a
snapshot of life in central London but
compared to the lockdowns in France and
Italy the difference is striking shops
are still open people are still walking
around driving around each and every
contact and opportunity for the virus to
spread I have a message for young people
you're not invincible even if you don't
get sick the choices you make about
where you go could be the difference
between life and death for someone else
until now restrictions in the UK have
been advisory rather than compulsory but
an order for schools to shut finally has
come into effect and the gates will not
reopen on Monday at his latest daily
coronavirus briefing the Prime
Minister's guidance to leisure venues
became a closure order we are
collectively telly telly cafes pubs bars
and restaurants to close tonight as soon
as they reasonably can and not to open
tomorrow newly published documents hint
at the struggle ahead UK government's
latest scientific advice makes sobering
reading sage has warned the government
that a combination of case isolation
household isolation and social
distancing of vulnerable groups is very
unlikely to prevent critical care
facilities being overwhelmed adding
general social distancing and school
closures to the mix would probably work
if kept in place for a long
period how long the government has been
warned that to be effective a policy of
alternating between more and less strict
measures would need to be in place for
at least most of a year around the world
governments are enacting emergency pass
imposing draconian restrictions and
confining whole populations in their
homes and there is no imminent exit
strategy
Paul Brennan al-jazeera